-This is a true story
based on a 2008
"New York" magazine article.
Can you just lay out for us
little bit what it's based on?
-It's based on these strippers
after the crash.
So, everything was great
until the crash.
Everybody was making money
All the Wall Street guys
are going into the strip clubs
The strippers
are making tons of money.
The guys are making
tons of money.
Then the stock market crashed.
Greed led to that, obviously
And they had to get
kind of resourceful.
And my character, Ramona,
is kind of the ring leader
the entrepreneur of the group.
-Yeah.
-And she decides, you know -
figures out a way
to get the money quicker.
I won't give away too much
but that --
But it is based on a true story,
a true article
that was written
in "New York" magazine.
-And you mentioned it also -
Female writer.
-Yes.
-You produced it.
Female producer.
-Yeah. All female --
female producers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Female director.
-Yeah.
-Female cast.
-Uh-huh.
-It's awesome.
-It's really great.
-It's actually awesome.
-And there, I mean ---
It's, I think, reflective
of a lot of the shortcomings
of movies up to this point
sort of a negative image.
The men barely say anythin
in this film.
-No. Nothing.
-Yeah, you aggressively go
working towards evening it out
[ Cheers and applause ]
And one of the way, like,
pretty quickly in the film
that you see the impact of tha
is I think strippers
historically in films
have been very
one-dimensional characters
-Also in the background. Right
-Yeah.
-And in every movie
you've ever seen,
there's, like, the strip clu
scene and blah, blah, blah
But this is from --
You know, it's kind of lik
"Goodfellas" when they went into
the mafia for the everyday
and you saw it from
the guys' point of view.
This is like --
This is the same thing.
Kind of going
into an underground world
that kind of
seems glamorous and sexy
but is super dangerous
and has a slippery slope.
And you get to see it from the
main characters' point of view
which is the women here.
-And it's great,
and it's also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's was a really lovel
camaraderie to the film.
In the group scenes.
It's so well cast.
Everybody's having --
-Oh, yeah.
-It seems like everybody's
having so much fun.
-We did. We did.
When all the girls were there,
it was like me and Constance Wu,
who plays kind of my best friend
in the movie,
and Cardi B and Lizzo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Lili Reinhart
from "Riverdale"
and Keke Palmer,
and it was just --
It was like we were all
in high school again.
-Yeah.
-It was amazing.
-There was some
very charismatic casting.
-Oh, my God.
-Like, everybody's really fu
to listen to in the film.
-It's a blast.
-Thank you.
-And then is it true that
when you were doing research
for this, because you
did do some research,
that A-Rod basically straight up
told you, like,
"I know some stuff
about strip clubs"?
-Not, "I know some stuff."
"I know everything."
"I know everything
you need to know."
And he was like,
"I was a baseball player.
He goes "Athletes,
we go to strip clubs."
So I was like
"I know. Okay. So tell me.
And he -- No,
but he actually did help me.
And I said --
This is how it opened up.
I said, "You know, I'm doing
this movie called 'Hustlers.
I play a stripper."
He's like, "Ohh."
And I go -- I go, "I'm gonna
have to visit some strip clubs."
And he was like, "Really?!
He's like, "Yeah, let's go
I'll go with you!"
He goes, "I can tell you
everything you need to know.
And he actually did give u
some great insight
from that side of it.
-When you brought him
to the strip clubs,
was everyone like,
"Hey, A-Rod! Good to see you"?
[ Laughter ]
-Thank God, no.
-Okay, that's good.
-That would have been
a bad night.
-Yeah, he had a punch card
Like, "If I get one more,
I get a free dance."
The movie's fantastic.
-Thank you.
-It's always so nice to see you.
Jennifer Lopez, everybody.